[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Eric is
with us Eric in Oklahoma City hi Eric
how are you hey hey Dave how are you
guys better than we deserve for sure
what's up perfect well hey my wife and I
we're kind of battling the idea of a few
financial decisions um between paying
off our student loans keep saving to buy
a house next year do we invest more how
much do we keep saving and so we're
really just kind of feeling a lot of
outside pressures to different decisions
and what we should do and we're just re
not really feeling clear on our next
steps and decisions and what
consequently you're not getting really
great traction on any of them right
right yeah lack of focus does that it
disperses the
energy right right and so right now
we're just kind of we have so many
options we're we're doing pretty good
financially um we don't have any debt uh
honey you have student loan debt yeah
besides their student loan debt that's
Deb how much student loan debt have you
got 200,000 good God Jesus
mcy we don't have much debt we're really
doing good I've only got 200,000 is to
that just came out of your mouth okay
okay yeah yeah yeah what's your
household income sir we are making about
130,000 a year combined what y all do so
I am a film director uh I specialize in
uh the film space uh video space here in
Oklahoma and my wife is an attorney and
that's where the law that the law
degrees with the 200,000 yeah yeah why
does she not make any money so she makes
about 105,000 a year oh so you don't
make any money okay just just about it's
my first year uh doing this uh so we're
hoping for we're seeing some some good
growth so far toward the end of this
year so you guys are how old are y'all
26 I'm 30 and she's 27 okay all right
well um and you're new to this whole
Ramsay thing apparently yeah we've we
took a course church last year with you
guys and uh it's where we learned a lot
of kind of financial pece University yes
correct huh okay uh you flunked you got
to go back um yeah cuz we you in that a
thing called the baby steps and it said
don't buy a house until you're out of
debt you remember that one yep do
remember that and it said uh we're not
investing until we're out of debt and
have an emergency fund in place because
we work the baby steps baby step two is
become debt free everything but the
house three is an emergency fund four is
investing into retirement and that gives
you the focus and the clarity that
you're looking for that was in that
class and that's what we teach and
that's what we've taught 10 million
people to do and that's why it's a pro
proven plan to financial Fitness y'all
have a mess dude you need to clean up
your $200,000 mess yeah just a little
bit that's what I'd be focusing on it's
not a little bit you need to quit
minimizing it it's you have a dad G big
old pile of manure right in the middle
of your living room
$200,000 is a lot of student loan debt
so you need to work on that let's get
that cleared up and then we'll build an
emergency fund then we'll save up for a
house and then we'll start our investing
that's your order of attack but don't
think you're going to do it but that's
what you should do this is the Ramsey
Show